[Music]
on this Monday night Calling it Quits
Ontario's housing Minister resigns from
his cabinet post over the green belt
controversy what it now means for
Premier Doug Ford do the right thing and
roll back this really dirty deal
escaping the muddy and miserable mess
that became Burning Man this is a
disaster the Scramble for drivers and
those fleeing on foot a Canadian
soldier's new Mission her powerful
message to survivors of military
misconduct and Ukraine's defense
minister gets dumped the allegations his
Department faced
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight mitu garcha good
evening and thank you for joining us
after weeks of pushback Ontario housing
Minister Steve Clark has announced he's
resigning from cabinet there have been
two scathing reports from the province's
Integrity commissioner and auditor
general over the development of the
province's Greenbelt lands Clark had
initially vowed to stay on despite the
controversy but after an emergency
Caucus meeting this afternoon he's now
been replaced and questions still remain
about what will happen to the land
Mackenzie gray has our top story tonight
a Labor Day resignation from one of
Ontario's most embattled politicians in
a letter posted to his Twitter account
Steve Clark acknowledging his role in
the Greenbelt Scandal takes away from
the housing emergency this crisis
demands someone who's not a distraction
from the important work that needs to be
done Clark said as someone who has given
my life to serving the people through
our Democratic institutions it is my
responsibility to adhere to the
principle of ministerial accountability
you know I think they were just delaying
the inevitable the right thing to do
would have been for him to resign but
ministerial accountability didn't appear
to be a concern for Clark on Thursday
when he resisted calls for his
resignation as housing Minister despite
showing some Contrition I want to make
it very clear to ontarians that I'm
sorry that we didn't do a better job and
that I personally didn't do a better job
in terms of the oversight last week
Ontario's Integrity commissioner found
that Clark was tasked with deciding
which lands to remove from protected
space outside of Toronto called the
green belt to be rezoned for housing
construction the report revealed Clark
was reluctant and stuck his head in the
sand deferring responsibility to his
chief of staff Ryan Amato who has now
also resigned the commissioner also
finding the process gave developers
direct input on which lands to select
with the Ontario auditor general saying
they stood to make over 8 billion
dollars from the deal this is here it's
going to keep going the RCMP is
considering whether to late charges and
and we'll see Ontario Premier Doug Ford
had backed Clark I have confidence in
Minister Clark he has a big file but now
is installed Paul Calandra is the new
housing Minister Ford also held an
emergency Caucus meeting this afternoon
with one Progressive conservative member
saying the government caucus has been
left reeling by Clark's resignation our
mandate is to build homes despite the
Scandal Ford has vowed to push forward
with his government's plan to build
homes on the Greenbelt lands this is a
counterproductive policy it's a dirty
policy from root to stem Clark's
resignation as a minister will give him
more time to handle any legal
consequences with the Toronto Star
reporting ethu he's hired outside legal
counsel all right Mackenzie gray in
Ottawa tonight thanks Mackenzie
a heat warning is in effect for much of
Southern Ontario including the greater
Toronto area temperatures could hit
between 30 and 34 degrees over the next
several days with the humidex making it
feel closer to 40. environment Canada
says this extreme heat is atypical for
September hot and humid conditions are
expected to ease on Thursday when a cold
front moves through the region
foreign West now Wildfire smoke is
putting a choke hold over millions of
Canadians tonight special air quality
statements are in effect for multiple
cities including Edmonton Calgary Regina
and Saskatoon there were worries the
smoke could cancel the cfl's annual
Battle of Alberta but the game has gone
ahead as planned there are some positive
news about the Wildfire situation in the
Northwest Territories essential workers
began returning to Yellowknife today
they will prepare Health Care Grocery
and Emergency Services ahead of the
expected return of residents on
Wednesday the city of twenty thousand
people was evacuated three weeks ago
when unprecedented wildfires encroached
on the community
in Saskatchewan a grim anniversary for
those living in James Smith Cree Nation
and Weldon today marks one year since
miles Sanderson went on a deadly
stabbing spree and his friends and
families mourn the loved ones they lost
they're also lamenting how it could have
been avoided as Nathaniel Dove explains
the tragedy has put a spotlight on
systemic failures indigenous communities
have had to endure the system has failed
us one year earlier a massacre 11 people
killed and 17 injured at James Smith
Cree Nation and in nearby weld in
Saskatchewan the chief blunt on the
failure he says caused it if we were
warned a year
in advance on how he was released
we would have caught on to this many in
the community very clear on what they
believe led to the violence residential
school
abuses alcoholism discrimination it all
combines
and drives people to do awful things
acknowledged and accepted by the federal
indigenous Services Minister this didn't
happen by accident this happened as a
byproduct of generations of families
being
similarly inflicted with loss and grief
and Trauma Ottawa has promised to help
pledging millions of dollars for a
treatment center and to start a First
Nations Police Service to respond faster
the indigenous Services Minister saying
it's urgent but gave no new commitments
on Monday and no new timelines meanwhile
the community is still grieving we just
finished celebrating our 10th year
anniversary on August 31st so four days
after that he passed away Sky
sanderson's husband Damien was one of
the first to Die the James Smith create
Community welcome media at previous
events not Monday the spokesperson
telling Global News this is the first
time some members have returned since
the attacks they're traumatized and many
feel afraid
Joyce Burns is one of the survivors I
don't feel comfortable when somebody
comes driving late at night
and our door is not very secure what is
clear when you're on is that a year is
not enough not to change what the
community says caused the violence and
not to recover my kids like miss him so
much and then
I miss him so much too because
he wasn't supposed to leave me
Nathaniel Dove Global News Toronto
after heavy rains trapped tens of
thousands in Nevada's remote Black Rock
Desert many attendees of this year's
Burning Man festival are getting out
conditions have improved enough for a
mass Exodus Jennifer Johnson reports on
the flood of people desperate for dry
ground
and we get
the weather has cleared the gates had
been reopened and the end to a
weekend-long nightmare is near tens of
thousands of Burning Man festival goers
are slowly getting out to get on with
their lives I think a lot of us knew
people didn't actually realize if it the
rain does get bad you can't leave that
never even crossed a lot of our minds
more than 70 thousand attendees were
told to shelter in place and ration
supplies after downpours flooded the
region closing roads creating ankle deep
muck and leaving porta potties unusable
we're out here with a solid group of
Veteran burners some people have been
doing this for 20 years and we've never
seen anything like this this is our
attempt to flee but the sludge didn't
stop some from making the treacherous
nine kilometer Trek out of the
campground to passable roads despite the
dangers including bear Kate and his wife
who needed to get home to their children
we took everything we needed to survive
on our backs there were actually rivers
that were flooding through the Playa
where we had to test and see how deep
they worked my wife was carried across
the river by a very strong man the local
sheriff's department is investigating
the death of one man in his 40s bicycle
can't move anymore
muddy muddy Burning Man The Counter
Culture annual Gathering held about 177
kilometers north of Reno has never
experienced such downpours dust storms
caused previous interruptions those with
RVs and trailers will still have to wait
for the sludge to dry before getting out
I think I could be trapped here for a
couple more days those still stuck are
hoping the weather will be clear enough
for the annual burn the man finale the
symbolic burning of a large wooden
Effigy which attendees then have to
clean up in the mass Mother Nature has
already caused
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
in Taiwan dozens have been injured after
typhoon hikeway tore across the island
[Music]
the storm made landfall yesterday
uprooting trees and cutting off power to
more than 160 thousand homes but despite
wind gusts reaching 200 kilometers per
hour there were no reported deaths or
any significant structural damage
businesses and schools remained closed
today while domestic flights and ferry
service to nearby Islands were canceled
it's the first major storm to hit Taiwan
directly in four years
torrential rains have killed at least
three people and caused widespread
damage in central Spain Road Subway
Lines and high-speed trains were shut
down after record rainfall caused heavy
flooding half a dozen bridges near
Madrid were ripped down by overflowing
Riverbanks residents were even warned
not to go outside or drive because of
the flooding the situation has improved
since yesterday with the National
Weather agency lowering its alert level
for the region from red to Yellow
the music world is in mourning Steve
Harwell the former frontman of the
popular rock band Smash Mouth has died
at the age of 56.
you're an All-Star get your game on go
play
according to the band's manager Harwell
died in his Idaho home surrounded by
friends and family he had been in
Hospice Care due to complications from
liver failure Harwell co-founded Smash
Mouth in 1994 and struggled with
alcoholism he eventually retired in 2021
due to health issues
[Music]
and singer-songwriter Gary Wright has
also died he was best known as leader of
the UK bass band Spooky Tooth and for
the back-to-back 1976 solo hits
Dreamweaver and Love Is Alive Wright had
a long battle with Parkinson's and
dementia he was 80 years old
Ukraine's critical shake-up in a time of
War coming up why the man who oversaw
the country's defenses is out of the job
days before the G20 Summit kicks off in
the Lee China's leader is ducking out of
the important Gathering China's foreign
Ministry confirmed president Xi Jinping
will be absent from the summit for the
first time since it began in 2008. a
delegation led by the country's Premier
will attend instead the reasons for xi's
absence are unclear but China and India
are embroiled in a border dispute over
the Himalayan region Russian President
Vladimir Putin also won't be attending
with the war in Ukraine expected to
remain a key issue at The Summit in
Ukraine a Russian drone strike damaged
warehouses at a grain port in Odessa the
attacks that buildings on fire hours
before talks between the Russian and
Turkish presidents Vladimir Putin says
the deal that allowed for the export of
Ukrainian grain through the Black Sea
won't be restored until the West helps
facilitate Russian agricultural exports
ports in the Odessa region have come
under heavy Fire by Russia since the
collapse of the Black Sea grain deal in
July
less than 24 hours after Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski revealed
plans to replace his defense minister
Alexi reznikov tendered his resignation
he posted a photo and letter on social
media saying it was an honor to serve
the Ukrainian people it is a major
shake-up happening at a critical time in
the war Crystal commencing Reports on
why now and who will replace him
Alexi reznikov forged bonds with
Canadian ministers and those of Allied
Nations over the last
558 days of Russia's full invasion now
Ukraine's charismatic defense minister
is out
he must be held accountable for what he
has done while holding the position of
Defense Minister says this soldier in
Kiev reznikov has not been named
directly but allegations of corruption
including military recruitment officers
taking bribes and mismanagement of funds
have plagued the defense department
the Ukrainian president was elected on
an anti-corruption platform on Sunday he
said the ministry needed a new approach
this international relations professor
says the president had to act but now
there has been a congruential factors
increasing the satisfaction in the west
particularly in the United States and
especially in the cases of political
party as to how the vast funds that are
being sent to support Ukraine are being
spent rustam umarov is the replacement
and is seen as clean with no links to
corruption and is a Crimean tartar
it's a way foreign school to reach out
to the Islamic world and say we are
finding a battle that is against
imperialism that is directed against
Ukraine as a country but also one that
is denying the right of the Tata
minority the Muslim minority with umarov
tapped as the new defense minister it
could also be taken as a sign that
Ukraine will not give up the fight to
reclaim Crimea Crystal commencing Global
News London
still ahead the lifeline blocked for
tens of thousands of Armenians living in
Azerbaijan
the government of the mostly ethnic
Armenian Enclave of nagorno-karabakh
says the blockade of a road enforced by
Azerbaijan has become a humanitarian
disaster it started in December and has
led to shortages of food Fuel and
Medicine in the region
nagorno-karabakh is internationally
recognized as part of Azerbaijan but
since the end of the Soviet Union much
of it has been autonomous and closely
Allied to Armenia since an armed
conflict in the region in 2020 Russia
has played an important peacekeeping
role there but armenia's prime minister
now says that relying on Moscow was a
mistake Redmond Shannon reports
these are the empty store shelves of
nagorno-karabakh with little hope for
new deliveries anytime soon video from
its public broadcaster illustrating what
residents say is part of a deliberate
plan by Azerbaijan leadership to starve
people out there is no egg there is no
chicken there is no milk and diary in
hospitals we have already serious
shortage of life-saving
medication for most of the summer almost
all of the traffic into the mostly
ethnic Armenian Enclave also known as
artsak has been blocked Azerbaijan says
the blockade is to prevent shipments of
Arms from Armenia which has relied on
support from Russia during the fighting
in 2020 Azerbaijan reto control of
territories in and around
nagorno-karabakh it meant the remaining
ethnic armenian-controlled land was
surrounded and needed a special Corridor
to link it to Armenia in the peace deal
that followed Russia was a guarantor of
what's become known as the Lash in
Corridor armenia's prime minister now
says involving Moscow was a strategic
mistake with Vladimir Putin's
concentration focused on Ukraine we feel
that the Arctic problem is not getting
the attention it deserves Azerbaijan
refutes allegations it's to blame for
the suffering here and denies trying to
starve the ethnic Armenian population
the government of Azerbaijan is strongly
committed to guarantee and secure the
access of this residence to the
necessary goods and establishing
appropriate living conditions for them
Azerbaijan says it has offered an
alternate trade route from within its
borders but those inside
nagorno-karabakh fear a trap that could
lead to a takeover it will be an attempt
to
impose your political will through this
seemingly humanitarian I mean no this is
a complete manipulation Armenia and
nagorno-karabakh are now pivoting from
Moscow to the West for help they say
smaller conflict in the shadow of a war
in Ukraine but one that's all too real
for the tens of thousands living it
Redmond Shannon Global News London
soldiering on next I speak with a
Canadian service woman about her
inspiration to compete in the Invictus
games
[Music]
hundreds of servicemen and women from 21
different countries are heading to
Germany this week where the Invictus
games are set to kick off the
international sporting event was founded
by Prince Harry in 2014 created for
wounded and Ill military personnel and
Veterans joining us is Major Joanna
Labonte who's among more than 30
Canadian soldiers competing in this
year's Edition major Levante thank you
for joining us first of all what
motivated you to apply to the Invictus
games and what does it mean to you to be
going
wow what motivated me to apply was the
soldier on program which is across the
country in Canada offering Sports and
creative activities for military members
and Veterans to just find their way and
find some hope and find some opportunity
through Sport and I was able to take
part in that and it's changed my life
you know I was encouraged to sign up for
the Invictus games and I was so honored
to be selected
I understand you also have a son as a
role model how do you think your
attendance at the games will inspire
young people while the Invictus games is
comprised of over 500 athletes from
around the world we have 31 Canadian
members going to the games and we are
from across the country so youth across
the country are going to see us
competing on an international stage I'm
sure it will inspire others I'm sure
youth will be engaged and want to also
find opportunities in sport and
Recreation now I understand your career
has found more than 30 years you've had
to step up for a range of posts in that
time this is a pretty unique one what
has preparation for these games look
like for you
well it started once we knew we were
selected in November and then we've gone
to two different training camps in
Canada where we got to bond with our
teammates learn new sports I'm doing
discus and shot put something I've never
done before and I've fallen in love with
these Sports it's an amazing opportunity
to learn something new and to find some
hope you know and to look to Fitness and
healthy living as a way forward for me
after I medically released from the
Canadian Armed Forces with the utmost
Sensitivity I also wanted to ask because
you are among I believe Four Women on
the Canadian team who've mentioned
military sexual trauma in your bio what
message do you hope your participation
on the international stage in this way
will send
military sexual trauma is is is a very
difficult thing to maneuver through to
come forward and disclose such a
sensitive thing has been a real
challenge for me and in fact in the end
it's it's why I'm releasing from the
Canadian Armed Forces but I don't look
at that as the end I look at it as the
beginning an opportunity to move forward
to figure out what's next for me and how
I can maybe hopefully Inspire other
sexual military sexual trauma survivors
to know that there's opportunities for
them in the future that they have
opportunities to really thrive in their
lives and that is indeed a very powerful
message major Joanna Labonte thank you
so much
thank you very much
and that is global national for this
Monday night I'm nitu Garcia tonight's
your Canada is Downtown Edmonton we love
seeing your Canada please keep emailing
your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
Donna will be back with you tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
thank you